Các bạn đều trai và tình bán đồ người bị bà tháng 5 công bố tình tiết mới,
liên quan tế vụ nổ xe, gần dí tích phá đại đào tại thủ đô nươi li.
Các bạn đều trai bán đấu cho thấy đây có thể là một tay nạn,
sản ra trong có trình vận chuyển và lựa đồng.
Thì nhóm nghĩ phạm trường mi thực hiện một âm mưu khổ bố, quý mỗi lớn.
Giới chức cho biết, có thể đã có tới 8,5 tế nửa trình Mỹ,
để tiến hành tất vụ tân công phối hợp tại nhiều khu vực.
Các bạn đều trai có ra đã tình thấy nhiều loại trình nổ và đạn dựa,
có mất lại tại hiện trường.
Đồng thời xe đánh ý phẩm trính là đất tựa của màn đã bị.
A đến thủ đột trong xe trường khớm với a đến của mẹ đối tượng giúp cộng các loại này.
Bộ nổ hông mù người thống bị một đã khiến hơn mươi người thích mạng,
hàng chục người bị thương và là mươi hại nhiều phương tiện xung quanh gà tổ điện gặm là khí là.
Nhà chức chức đang mở giọc đều trai đện hứng chẳng người cơ tận công tiếp sĩan.